where did Sean William Scott go he was
everywhere for a few years following the
success of 1999 s American Pie at
sequels but around 2010 it seems like he
pretty much disappeared here's what
probably led to Scott falling off
Hollywood's radar unpopular with critics
the bulk of Scott's films have been
critical duds though American Pie struck
a chord with critics and audiences alike
most of his movies haven't impressed
dude where's my car has an 18% rating on
Rotten Tomatoes dukes of hazzard and mr.
Woodcock each have a score of 13 just
before I go has a 10 and movie 43 has a
4-2 flicks
goon and role models are the exceptions
the scores of 80 and 78% respectively
you know what they say two out of seven
a pad unpopular with audiences Southland
Tales had a 17 million dollar budget but
only made about two hundred seventy
three thousand mr. Woodcock barely broke
even and bulletproof bunker and half of
its 52 million dollar budget back what
do they have in common
Scott in a leading role he's often heard
but not seen Scott has sustained his
career with voice over work the actress
plaids can be heard voicing crash in
four movies from the Ice Age franchise
Scott also voices crash in the
franchise's TV movies shorts and video
games least of his famous and securest
finances should be considering will
probably never stop making Ice Age
movies typecast at his peak Scott was
the goofy high schooler sleazy party boy
our college jock even if he was in his
late 20s and 30s when he took those
roles now that he's older he's not up
for those parts Scott got the memo
though in 2011 he told mtv news that his
role as American Pie Stifler may have
stifled his career I had so much fun and
loved the character but I don't want to
be known as that character forever now
I'm realizing that I probably will be
known as that character forever personal
issues in March 2011 Scott entered rehab
according to TMZ the actor voluntarily
entered treatment for unspecified health
and personal issues staying for 30 days
before filming American Pie for American
Reunion it's unclear what he was
struggling with as he hadn't addressed
anything publicly Scott insisted to
People magazine in 2003
I don't really party if I did it would
probably just be trying a new bottle
one Stifler would be ashamed avoids
publicity Scott often flies under the
radar and has rarely seen at events or
photographed on the street in an era of
celebrity blocking on a 24-hour news
cycle this otherwise respectable
behavior may have actually hurt him
Scott's invisibility between projects
may have made audiences forget him
what's next
things haven't worked out for Scott the
way we thought they would since he first
found famous Stifler but that doesn't
mean we've seen the last of him a goon
sequel called last of the enforcers will
hit in 2016 after the release of Ice Age
collision course maybe Scott can call up
his old pal Ashton Kutcher and see about
putting together a follow-up - dude
where's my car
anyone up for dude where's my uber
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to see more videos like
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to tell us why you think
Hollywood's not calling Sean